what's that special thing that makes us
different from animals it's our ability
to imagine to dream and to believe in
ideas that don't exist yet this man had
an idea he saw the problem of poor
sanitation and degrading life conditions
and fast urbanizing cities and believed
that order symmetry and standardization
could be the solution he separated all
the functions into different zones in
order to clear congestion and improve
transportation he saw the cramped living
conditions the lack of light and air and
existing urban centers and believed that
we needed to build tall monolithic
skyscrapers which will bring light and
fresh air while leaving lots of open
space for roaming around he believed
that his ideas would help create a
better society
[Music]
this man had an idea he saw the blighted
neighborhoods a lack of sanitation and
the cramped living conditions and
believed that by replacing these slums
with these powers in the park but they
could make way for better quality
housing and better quality citizens he
believed that the residents of New York
deserved lush green spaces and that the
children deserve to run around these
parks breathe fresh air and play with
other children he dreamt of open roads
and highways that would connect
different cities and he called these the
lungs for the
[Music]
this boy had an idea he saw that
everyone on his blog was suffering from
the heat it was high muggy and miserable
so when he was at school he went to the
janitor's closet grab the wrench and put
it in his backpack so that when he got
home he could crack open the fire
hydrant maybe he'll get in trouble but
he believed that this would save his
neighbors from the heat but when he got
home the buildings were gone there was
nothing but rubble and debris his
neighborhood had been designated a slum
and they had to move into a tall
concrete building some of his neighbors
were not able to come there were no
shops no restaurants and no life on the
street when it got dark nobody went
outside
some people questioned whether it was an
intentional that the bridges were built
too low so that the public buses could
not get through restricting and glowing
and residents from accessing certain
suburbs
some people questioned whether it was
intentional at freeways were built right
next to certain neighborhoods to limit
growth and access does it really matter
an idea can't be a good idea unless
everyone's voices are heard
[Music]